it is really hard not only to like
innovating in science is hard and
getting something to work is hard and
and and both Angel and gizm have been
you know faced all kinds of issues to
get this stuff to work but but then just
just the idea of being a young person at
that stage of the career and um having
something that's so different and kind
of counter expectation it it's a lot of
pressure and it's a lot of um yeah it's
a lot of responsibility and I just you
know I think people should understand
that like it's hard for anybody else
listening to this um you know who might
be in that position or might be
considering going into it um I I don't
know what what you all feel but to me
it's as as hard and and as um uh as much
pressure as it is it's the most fun you
can have I think